it was just physically impossible for
Muslims to pull this off and the
sophistication and never forget that
Islam and Muslims had nothing to do with
9/11 and stop using us as the escape
word the Bedouins said Wednesday our and
the Prophet peace be upon him said when
honesty is lost and the bed westerwelle
prophet allows messenger how can honesty
be lost I was just being thrown around
and I didn't know where I was and it was
very scary and then all of a sudden I
said Allah and all of a sudden is like
snan I I saw and I saw a being in front
of me sitting smiling I couldn't see his
face but I felt a huge smile on me I
cannot describe it all is l am islam
says love all mankind and that's why
we're sharing this message peace
acquired by submission to the one and
only one creator that has an erv God
Almighty Allah
I'm doing come to LA please forgive my
technological handicaps no worries no
worries how you been
alhamdulillah hamdulillah good good and
you good hamdulillah al hamdulillah huh
how's house
how you handling the whole the whole
situation what's going on today in the
world I get up in the morning I pray
Fajr I mean who do I professor I had my
breakfast I watched the news when I feel
full of that
well after I pray I read a little Quran
get focused
what's the news just you know Muhammad
peace be upon him had Scouts it's nice
to know what the other side is doing and
then I just mind my own business I take
care of my wife I put her around the
house keeping things clean I'm starting
to put my autobiography on to Facebook
check but I've 6 or 7 minutes at a time
I've been wanting to publish it but it's
been a drag to do and now the things are
the way they are I just want to get
destroyed of my life out there so people
can see it so it's not Facebook little
by little it's coming out little by
little and staying and just asking Allah
to keep me close and to take care of my
you know - just - I've been looking at
this whole thing since I was 14 Eddy
when they invented the term conspiracy
theory I was 14 and Kennedy had just
been killed and they threw shade on
anybody who was trying to find the truth
and that's when the term conspiracy
theory started and I gotta tell you the
events of the last week or so a whole
bunch of strands open some pearls fell
off the Strand this week and I'm just
biding my time and being patient and
watching things unfold and asking a lot
to keep me in his in his circle and his
close to him and peace inside I'm not
afraid of anything going on in this
world my eyes I'm on a journey we're all
you know we're all on a journey this is
this is not the main event this is you
know we're going somewhere and this is
part
the journey you know you gave a list of
things that you do wake up in the
morning you pray pray fudger
and then you go on you read the Batum
Word of God Almighty and its original
the Quran I spent some time with the
family so it's business as usual
I don't go out hardly at all you know my
body is 71 years old and I have some
medical issues so I'm considered
high-risk anything happened to me the
odds are it would kill me but I read I
hear about these veterans 100 year old
veterans coming out of the hospital
cured you know it's like I don't believe
there's anybody's got a death sentence
on them until they stop breathing so but
I have been I haven't been playing in
traffic you know I've been staying
inside I gotta tell you the my students
around here there's three masses in this
area and as I said I'm 71 and I've got
some issues my wife has some medical
issues and I gotta tell you the spirit
of Islam in the Muslim communities here
is better is worth more than gold it's
worth more than gold it's like it's like
these people it's just like I've been
Muslim ten years and I feel like I'm
being taken care of like I'm everybody's
grandfather not just my own kids and
it's just so wonderful it's such a
blessing it's such a blessing it's an
ego it's an ego death to get over
receiving the kind of help that I need
right now but this is part of the
journey to you know what does it say
Muhammad peace be upon him said the hand
that gave us is better than the hand and
receives or something like that but he
didn't say it's bad to receive he said
Givens better receiving is good to when
you need it and I've been on both sides
of that so a lot split me on the other
side of the table for a little while and
I'm learning to be humble more you know
the old male ego wants to go I could do
this myself no you can't you can't even
take a breath now we had you on the
program before and we had your whole
kind of highlights of your story for
those people that didn't get a chance to
watch that kind of bring up bring us up
to speed you were you were around 13 14
years old if I remember you had your Bar
Mitzvahs yeah you came from a Jewish
family and then ya said you said you
accepted this beautiful way of life the
way of life of Jesus Moses Abraham the
last
messenger sent to mankind Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon them all the
submission has surrendered to the one
and only one creator the heavens and
earth the one they submitted to and
that's the one word Islam you would
select accepted this way of life of all
the prophets and messengers around ten
years ago just kind of up somehow just
kind of recapping what was it and why
what was it that did it for you that had
you accept this beautiful way of life
okay I'll try to be brief well I guess
said when I was 14 I got initiated onto
the path of the truth because we all
know that they were they were zooming us
with this one shooter story the same way
they're zooming us now with the two
planes taken down the World Trade Center
so I've been following false Flags and
phony headlines since I was 14 that's 56
57 years ago now and one thing led to
another and I studied and I learned
about Kennedy and then I learned about
Vietnam I was in college I'll try to
I'll try to try to encapsulate this I
went from one false flag to another and
looked behind the scenes and sawa there
was something going on but I couldn't
put it all together when 9/11 happened
it was just physically impossible for
Muslims to pull this off and the
sophistication and everything and the
nature of the demolition and the level
of the violence they couldn't have done
it it was impossible and yet just like
the Nazis used to say if you want to
believe people I make it a big one so
they made it a huge lie and so many
people still believe it and well I
learned it to Muslims didn't do it
you're talking about you're talking
about 9/11 9/11 it was physically and
physiologically and chemically and
biologically it was impossible on every
level
and yet people hate it I was defending
the Muslims saying they couldn't have
done it and my friends I was a Muslim
yet my friends would say why you just
said Muslims man I say I'm not defending
the Muslims man I'm defending the truth
they couldn't have done it it's like I
was being objective
I wasn't being like my side versus your
side it was like I was my side is the
truth I've been like jumping fences
since I was 14 looking for the truth I
wasn't gonna let some man-made barriers
stop me now you know so after ten years
Muslims and talking about 9/11 and
making people try to think about it
I have I had a moment my son called me
and I was in Arkansas in the Ozarks and
I had a little ham store selling him
clothing and stuff and um it wasn't a
head shop or anything like that it was
telling him products you know clothing
and for you know paper and stuff anyway
um he basically he gave me Dawa and he
told me he said he knew I've been
looking all my life he watched me when
he was growing up and he said he gave me
he gave me Dawa and he invited me and he
told me and I told me where to look in
the in the Torah and the Bible and the
gospel certain quotes and I said I would
think about it I was looking at it and
basically I was afraid for him I thought
he was a terrorist or something because
I didn't know anything I was blinded by
his Lomb except I knew they couldn't
have done this one thing at 9/11 I
didn't know any Muslims and one night
after my son invited me I had a moment a
couple of things happened one one was
there was a noise so loud and I thought
my house was falling down around me that
her plane had crashed into our house and
I opened my eyes and there were crickets
it was totally silent totally silent I
went back to sleep and I had a dream and
I saw a man and I couldn't see his face
but I could tell he was smiling at me
and I described him to my first Imam and
he said vomit visited you you got to see
Muhammad he was it was so he was had a
gold turban of like a gold colored
turban and a gold shawl he was dressed
in white and he was smiling it was light
all around him and I couldn't see his
face and it was right and my ribcage
opened up like a French doors and and I
felt like I was exploding inside and no
it all came together the words in the
books I was looking at were standing on
little pillars of fire it was like the
words that I was looking at that my son
told me to read like in Deuteronomy and
in John 16 and in Isaiah and different
places it just like popped out 3d at me
and it was like yes it was like yes and
I just felt like I was home I felt like
the search was the search was over at
one level and then the search was
beginning on another level to learn my
Dean now to spend my the rest of my life
learning what this is so but so you had
a degree you had you you actually had a
dream of the last and final messenger
prophet muhammad peace and buzz' to be
upon him you had a dream of him
the night that I experienced the this
was truth what my son had told me I had
a dream and I and I I saw and I saw a
being in front of me sitting smiling I
couldn't see his face but I felt a huge
smile on me I cannot describe it all I
saw was like a you know a turban and Sun
and you know a shawl and just a beat
just like and I felt a huge smile but I
couldn't see his face but I felt this
huge gigantic smile on me and I told my
first Imam about it and he told me he
said he said that you got to see
Muhammad so anyway that's not what
convinced me I was convinced before I
saw him I was convinced not having seen
him seeing him didn't convince me I got
to make that clear though everything
that had led me to the point where my
son invited me and I had that epiphany
that's a Christian word but it's it's
like like a realization spiritual
realization I just felt I don't know I
felt it was like a lottery I don't know
how to describe you say a lot revealed
it to me you sound like you're some kind
of a you know you saw some God trip so I
don't want to say but he did but he did
he did reveal it to me that this is true
because you can be standing in front of
the PRU truth and not see it unless he
lets you see it you know this is
something I'm learning is because I
asked myself how come I can't explain
this objectively to people who were
smarter than me and it's not my fault
and I'm thinking there's something wrong
with me and it's not a lot puts a cover
over people's eyes for whatever reason
something is in their heart it's not
their time to hear it yet I don't know
why I'm not judging them I'm just saying
it's not up to me that people get the
message that's not my job my job is to
be the try to be the best person I can
be conveying the message with the best
manners I can convey don't get into
mudslinging on social networks stay
elegant remember the Prophet with the
blood in his shoes getting stoned at and
not don't get into name-calling and all
that terrible stuff that's a sin try to
stay elegant remember who we represent
we represent the Most High God
we represent Allah we represent we're
inviting people to come to Allah we
don't have to stoop to these low levels
of communication that exist on social
networks when you're there's a lot of
people that are sincere and want to hear
this so I advise myself off sometimes I
get caught we all do and I advise
everyone listening don't get caught in
them and mudslinging or verbal cage
fighting and calling that one verbal
case Friday yeah yeah yeah yeah I tell
people I tell people I don't like yeah
feel free it's in the public domain yeah
you too Eddie you inspire me you inspire
me you know
so anyway go ahead so so now it wasn't
so you had something that's amazing I
mean to be able to have this dream of
prophet mohammed salah salem but you
said it wasn't you were convinced of
islam before that wasn't was it the
authenticity of the crowd was the simple
theology of worshipping the creator
alone not the creation doing being
morally upright was it that was it the
consistency with the the chain of
revelation coming from being able to put
it in a chronological order that it
wasn't confusing like many people get
confused with the many religions all
right I'll tell you I'm gonna answer you
the same way I answer you know I say
this you know there's only one cause of
death there's only one cause suggest
Allah took you there sir the rest is
details your car accident dine your
sleep coronavirus whatever these are not
the cause of judge the cause of death is
the law decided you go now so by the
same token what I'm saying to you is
that I
known I could have been studying all
this all my life I could have been I
could have had it down I could have
known every chapter and verse and I
wouldn't have seen it I could have been
a drunk in a gutter and if Allah wanted
to show me this he would have showed it
to me I can't take any credit for
anything I can't explain this I I was
diligently with eyes open seeking the
truth but I had no idea what it would be
and when I when it did hit me in that
nanosecond like you know the thumb slap
in between the eyes
that Islam is true it was like that was
the last thing in the world I would have
thought it was the last and I had I was
laughing and crying at the same time and
I just want to say debt cryin that night
that I had that realization the tears
weren't rolling down my face Eddie the
tears were flying out of my eyes like
birds eyes watching him I was watching
the tears fly out of my face they were a
trajectory they were going out of me I
never saw such a thing a mile I felt
like I was in a Disney movie I was
looking at the tears flying out of my
and I wasn't tripping or no artificial
you know stimulus or anything like that
it was coming out of the tears were
flying out of my face I know it's just I
it was just overwhelming
he said he humbled me to a point i had a
dream shortly after that that I was like
just floating out in space and I was
getting thrown every which way and I had
no ground beneath me and no heaven above
me and I was just being thrown around
and I didn't know where I was and it was
very scary and then all of a sudden I
said Allah and all of a sudden is like
snap and I just feel like either he was
testing me or Shaitaan was messing with
me or something because it was just
feeling like you were falling out of an
airplane or something and uh and then
all of a sudden I just I called out to
Allah and everything everything was
mellow it was just I never and that
didn't happen again but it's just in the
everyday life the the you asked me this
question like what turned me it was a
combination of things I can't it's like
you eat a meal and it's got all these
ingredients in it
and somebody says did the chef says what
did you like about it the best it was
like what did you like the salt the
pepper the spices the cayenne the
turmeric the it was the combination it
was the whole thing is it's like a lot
revealed it to me that's all I got he
gets all the credit he gets all the
glory you know I could have been
studying this on my life or I could have
been out chasing women or drinking or
partying or what if he wanted me you
would have got me yeah so you know or I
could have been a month and I was you
know so I was that tube so in my search
so I just feel so blessed it saved from
what could happen to me
mm-hmm when I was 13 I was bar Mitzvahed
I was Jewish and Jewish family it born
into and my parents gave me a choice
they said you wanted to have a party or
go to Israel and have a visit and I said
I want to have a party and I've seen a
lot of my generation turn into like
really monsters people who are like they
go over to Israel they get some land and
they start shooting up Palestinians like
they own the place and that could have
been me easy could have been me my
parents didn't know the secret agenda
going on over there they were good they
didn't know the horrific things going on
there they were they were most American
Jews don't have a clue what's happening
over there they don't know the hidden
agenda of the Zionist movement and what
it's got to do with the Antichrist and
the false messiah coming who one-world
government most of the mayor most
American Jews they think it's like to
help the poor Jews for World War two but
it's not anyway I don't want to get into
a political you know I said enough about
that yeah but that when I look when I
look at where I am now and I look at
where I could have been I just it's like
being having been in the ocean
surrounded by sharks and somebody threw
you a robe I'm telling you I you know
you know about the the Jewish scholars
during the time of Prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him who also
they also when they were looking they
were looking for the signs the gia the
Jews were there for a reason right in
Medina they were waiting for lace
updates the place of dates tell us about
that and tell us about those scholars
also who were sincere who are humble
like yourself for true seekers they
didn't let nothing stop them from
accepting after they verified in their
own books the Torah after they looked at
Prophet Muhammad and they observed him
and they tested him that they confirmed
that he's the final messenger sent by
the creator of the heavens and earth yes
there's one there's one in particular I
know the story of forgive me if I look a
little green it's because I had one of
these banker lamps it's got a green
glass shade so I look a little I got a
green cast on me and I'm not sick or
anything they're just little green here
there was a there was a rabbi his name
was Jose Hossein bin Salim and he was a
rabbi during the time of Muhammad peace
be upon him and he was waiting for the
Prophet that was foretold to come to the
place of dates and he heard about
Muhammad and this man was a Torah
scholar and he was well respected and
all his congregation thought he was like
the greatest rabbi you know ever so just
trying to get sorry I'm just trying to
get comfortable here fine am I still
with you're still there good is good so
so he knew he knew you know he was like
he was like a student a seeker of truth
he wasn't gonna let a fence or a barrier
stop him so he heard about Muhammad he
went to see Muhammad peace be upon him
and he asked him the there are certain
questions that rabbis have to discern a
prophet and he asked the rabbi these
questions I don't know them all one of
them has to do with who did you come for
came for the poor not the rich and so
forth I don't know all the questions but
he asked him three or four questions
Muhammad peace be upon him answered all
the questions perfectly of course and
Hossein rabbi Jose Nevin Salim said I
want to
there's no deity worthy of worship been
here the Prophet he became Muslim right
there
so so Prophet Muhammad said to him let's
go what about your people what about
your congregation and you said you said
because Muhammad peace be upon him said
they've been giving me a lot of grief
your congregation you know
so he said what are we going to judge
but so they set up and they set up a
situation they set up a scenario
so anyway Muhammad peace be upon him
gave Hossein even sell him a new name
Abdullah bin sanam okay slave of Allah
servant of Allah okay so he gave him the
name abdullah even stalin became a close
companion and he told him to stay in the
tent stay in his tent and then he got
one of his Sahaba to call all the Jews
over to his tent to stand outside he was
going to talk to them so he talked to
them he they all came around and he said
to them who do you say this Hossein
tipping solemn is what kind of a rabbi
who is he and the Jews are gone he's a
wonderful man he's the greatest rabbis
and sliced bread and you know I just
love to be smart he knows the Torah like
the back of his hand he's the greatest
guy
okay so then Mohammed said I don't know
the exact peace be upon him I don't know
if he came brought out rabbi you know or
if he wasn't a rabbi anymore he was a
companion he was still a teacher but he
came out and anyway after they found out
he was a the bottom line is when they
found out he became a Muslim and that he
you know recognized the Prophet they all
started cursing him out saying he was a
dog and he was bad guy and he was didn't
know nothing he was worthless and you
know piece of dirt so that's how it goes
that's how it goes there's a brother
there's an imam or a brother a scholar
in England Abdul Rahman green they're
big tall guy red hair you know what I'm
talking about right now dude Rahim green
yeah you know him right
yes yes he tells the story about he's
got a friend who's a rabbi and he says
to the rabbi one day they're gonna
friends he says rabbi you know my mom is
real right he goes rabbit goes yeah I
know there everybody I know mom it's
true it's there so why don't you tell
your congregation and around I said if
they don't follow their own profit what
makes you think they're gonna follow
anybody else's turn around yeah this was
a rabbi talking
he's got they got tough jobs they're
wearing wayward arts just neck people
you know so what are you gonna do
may Allah item more
there's this word you used you said that
this was created you said earlier this
is something that you've gone down a lot
of these weeds call rabbit holes would
you call them yes and there's a term you
call you you you said that was coined
for what reason conspiracy theorists
what is a conspiracy theory when when
people started poking around the Kennedy
assassination to try to figure out what
really happened
the CIA coined that term and put it out
into the public into the society and
they have something there called slides
you know how you put a slide into a
slide projector and it projects an image
on a screen they have they have I think
they might have scrubbed this
information from the computer because I
can't find it anymore but they have
these things called slides which are
trigger words and things like that that
automatically change a person's brain
and make them to think in a different
direction with like conspiracy theory it
automatically throws shade mittens it
throws doubt it's kind of like in the
Zionist game book the Zionist playbook
101 questioned the mental capacity of
the opponent they all say oh you're
crazy and you're this and you're that
Sigmund Freud who was you know big in
with the with the Tavistock Institute of
the Zionists and so forth he was like
the power of though guys who had the
psychiatry in the psychology degrees
they could think of destroy a person
just by saying something about them the
person didn't have to be guilty all en
dessous is say that person is crazy or
that person is out of their mind and if
you get into an any kind of a debate
with a a hardcore Zionist the first
thing they're gonna do just about is
attack your mental state they're gonna
call you they're gonna call into
question your mental state and this is
just what they do this is what they do
so you don't go near that any more once
you know you're dealing with somebody
like that
you cut bait you go fish somewhere else
this is what I used to tangle with
people like this and waste so much
energy and I found out it was a sin I
thought I was trying to like do
something good yeah so this is so this
is a stigma that's attached
- now obviously there's there's people
who delight in this and there's some
things that are far-fetched and way out
there but there might be something out
there that because we know the
mainstream media has known to lie
there's you know for instance we can
give some examples like you just gave
one that the majority of the world is
convinced about but let's go to
something that's not even the we'll get
to that one in a second but let's let's
something that's just been proven fact
maybe you can add to these weapons I'm
just trying to get myself so you
probably know much more of these but let
me start off with a few you have weapons
of mass destruction now this was
something that was perpetuated the media
pushed it they had brought down their
experts everybody the whole world was
fooled and then again it was turned out
that it was a lie yes so that's one
example you have the babies and
incubators you remember that one thank
you - Thank You Barry and let the
children to die on the cross for the US
public is outraged the result support
for land war zooms it's a turning point
Desert Storm is launched 135,000 Iraqis
are killed an estimated 1 million Iraqis
many of them children and old people
then died as a result of 10 years of
sanctions one small problem
there never were any incubator baby
deaths not one the Canadian Broadcasting
Corporation's investigative flagship
program the Fifth Estate reveals the
girl to be the Kuwaiti ambassador's
daughter given her lines and coached in
acting by the giant American PR firm
Hill & Knowlton it's one phase in a ten
million dollar joint USQ ad campaign of
deception this man is lying I myself but
at forty newborn babies that had been
taken from their incubators this man is
lying and they had kids and incubators
and they were thrown out of the
incubators so the Kuwait could be
matically dismantled there were a lot of
people who participated in a conspiracy
yes an out-and-out conspiracy of fake
organizations false documents fraud and
disinformation that's when they had the
woman coming on crying that they were
killing babies and the incubators then
then later that was also came out as a
lie the false pretense of evading many
of these countries Afghanistan and
whatnot these were based on just lies
the gulf of tonkin for instance you know
that one that was a false flag yeah
that's clear that's nothing that that's
it just came out now Robert did the
Secretary of Defense Robert McNamara on
his deathbed confessed because he didn't
want to go to his grave with that on his
brain on his car on his soul yeah that
he admitted it was a false flag before
he died and this guy was the secretary
of defense during the Vietnam War of a
big part of it and he admitted it he
admitted it so yeah well the government
had so what if they admit it but they
still do what they do
the government was found guilty of
assassinating Martin Luther King - on a
civil court nobody knows this or very
few people know it it's like there
there's a huge juggernaut happening
between it's a big battle between good
and evil you know it and I know it we're
coming down to the wire the last days
the end times the time before the hour
so you know people are complaining about
Trump but he's fulfilling a prophecy
you know when the Bedouin came to the
prophet has said when is honesty gonna
you know when is the hour you know that
one right the Bedouin said when's the
hour and the Prophet peace be upon him
said when honesty is lost and the
Bedouin said well prophet allows
messenger how can honesty be lost
he says when there's unfit leaders and I
think that Trump is becoming such a
graphic example of this it's like I feel
like Elijah's going look look
can you can you see this can you see how
unfit this is you know I mean it doesn't
get a whole lot more unfit but again may
Allah guide him to
guide him I'd love it if he woke up
tomorrow morning and said I had a I had
a dream like like I had yeah you know
but I don't know if that's gonna happen
but tell us so now if someone comes
along and questions the official
narrative are were you saying that now
this term there's holes in the story and
they're in a theory so if you question
that whatever is pushed out by
mainstream media if you question that
then this was developed this term was
coined to stigmatize you and to label
you if that you can lose your job you
can lose your family you could lose your
social position you could lose your your
key to the bathroom the executive
bathroom you can lose your your freedom
they could they could they could you
know they could figure out some some
charges against you if they wanted to
that you know what we're coming up to
now is they want to make it against the
law to to criticize the coronavirus prop
Allah sees they want to make it against
the law to criticize Israel they want to
take away our freedom of speech we can
criticize our own government but they
want to make it illegal for us to
criticize what's going on in the
occupied lands of the Zionists or by
occupying right now we're not we could
be punished for talking about it I mean
again I don't want to get too excited
about all the detail because this is
just another rung in the ladder it's
just another step in in the process of
what's going on that's all so are you so
you mentioned so I asked you because you
mentioned that term and then you
mentioned 9/11 because a lot of this was
a catalyst from the 9/11 all of these
wars and any of the other civil
liberties being taken away so now if you
question if there's which there are I
mean thousands of architects and
engineers there there's many people
intellectuals academics Christian
professors you know who are coming out
and they're questioning the official
story so are all of them conspiracy
theorists and are you hundred percent
not 99 but 100 percent convinced that is
that Muslims had no
thing to do with building seven coming
down what I'm gonna say is this who took
down the towers and who pulled off to
all the tragedies on 9/11 or a
combination of people consisting of
people from different countries people
with different political leanings and
I'm and they're made and I wouldn't put
it I believe there were some Muslims
involved but they by no means
masterminded this by no means were they
the ones who who pulled this off and
masterminded it they may have been
players but I don't believe I don't
believe at all that they were in any
control of the operation at all do you
think that do you think that Islam and
Muslims were used as a scapegoat
absolutely absolutely because the powers
that be is it's a very simple connecting
the dots the powers that be are trying
to hijack the planet do you populate the
humanity dumbest down with with
chemicals and and diseases and and
vaccinations and foods and stuff like
that and pretty much turn this world
into their private Country Club and it's
not going to happen because this is the
this is the gospel of the godless this
is their dream of the future okay God
has other plans and he's the best
planner and his plans gonna prevail now
I have to ask you Eddie am i wandering
am i digressing or am i am i answering
your question no you're answering that's
what uh yeah my question was do you do
you believe that Muslims were in Islam
was used as the scapegoat
you answered it yes I believe he's long
was used as a scapegoat yes I believe
that there may have been some Muslims
involved in pulling this off yes but do
I believe that they were like the 19
hijackers and all that stuff
I don't believe it happened like they
said at all I believe no none of that
there were direct energy weapons the
plane the thing was vaporized the
buildings were vaporized it was like a
space weapon he was like direct energy
weapons were used demolition was used
they even said there was on the Richter
scale there was a 2.6 tremor under the
World Trade Center before the planes
arrived you could check me out there was
a trend there was a small nuclear
explosion or high-intensity explosion
under the everybody's talking about it
all the firemen all the first responders
that blew out the bottom of the place
blew out there are there are beams in
the basement there are cut with a with a
electric saw you can see it but nobody
is like that nobody's talking pay no
attention to the you know pay no
attention to the everybody is afraid to
but like when Kennedy got shot I was 14
I'm walking around go how come nobody's
talking about this how come nobody is
questioning it and I think that the
general mood was hey if they're gonna
blow off the head of the president the
United States in broad daylight on
television I'm not gonna make any peeps
I'm not gonna make a sound you know
that's what I think was the general and
a few brave people stood up and a few
brave people stood up and a lot of
people that actually were eyewitnesses
on 9/11 that are dead people who were
working for the city there were even
there were from call from prostitutes
to city managers people who were privy
to information from hearing stories or
being a witness to somebody talking
about something and doing something and
so many of them died it's on YouTube you
go and you see their testimony of these
people the people who actually saw the
airplane they said I I personally
believe that there were no airplanes
there that's my personal belief my
personal belief is these were 3d
holograms and because they found a jet
on the street they said it was from the
crash
it doesn't match any of the planes that
apparently hit the hit the World Trade
Center and when you watch these videos
the wings disappear and appear
this thing was CGI and this was done
with direct energy weapons controlled
demolition am i dying am I going too far
off the beam here there were Israeli
artists quote-unquote artists inside the
World Trade Center for months before it
went down apparently to create some kind
of art project I believe in my heart of
hearts they were wiring the place they
were wiring the place and you can see
from the slow-motion videos where these
little pops are coming out it's like a
control gel militia is no question and
then you said building seven you
mentioned building seven and it just
fell at the end of the day what's the
what's the what's the logic behind that
that one one thing is that it's you know
when you get into some of these things
with the CGI and stuff for many people
it can be very overwhelming but when you
see a building just come down like a
controlled demolition I mean that's
something that's easy to to look at and
to decipher that hold on and to see no
there was no plane that actually hit
that building so that's where many of
the architects and engineers you're
looking at they're they're like hold on
and the controlled demolition experts
and that's where people are really
questioning because this is right in
front of their eyes they're seeing it
there was a lot of very sensitive
information in the World Trade Center
and there was also a whole lot of gold
belonging to various countries in vaults
underneath the World Trade Center that
nobody seems to be able to find right
now there were there were CIA offices
there were places that there were
records in that in that complex that
they needed to they needed to to big to
shred okay too much to shred so they did
it that way it was too much to stretch
now why did they do it
why did they take it down you know
I had a friend and I have a friend and
he and I used to deliver vegetarian food
organic food in New Jersey and we used
to kid around in the 90s and say
wouldn't it be cool if you could lay the
World Trade Center down sideways turn it
into a hothouse think of all the food
you could grow and I just thought to
myself if this thing had been hit by an
airplane and it was gonna fall it would
have it wouldn't turn into dust period
end of story
I'm not I'm not laughing from laughing
I'm laughing from its nervous it's a
really nervous you know it's not funny
yeah so yeah I just saw I brought these
questions up because you mentioned the
9/11 and a lot of times people to this
day they will question Muslims I'll be
in the back of their head you know those
people it's always associated there's
always a stigma and every time September
11 9 a round and so he's never forget so
do you do you believe what do you think
should should Muslims continue to go
with the not all but some who would
still continue to go with the official
story or should Muslims start standing
out and saying stop never forget that
Islam and Muslims had nothing to do with
9/11 and stop using us as the escape
goal well when I first became Muslim I
was on a roll talking about it all the
time just because I was into the truth
which I still AM and it wasn't about
being into being Muslim and it was into
being the truth and that's what led me
that's the beauty of my journey I was
looking for the truth I wasn't looking
for anything else and I didn't care what
it made me look like or where it took me
and where it took me I had to trust
because if I knew where I was going I
wouldn't be on a search would I so I
didn't know what I was gonna find so I
had to trust suratul baqarah I don't
know I'm not a scholar I don't know the
exact quote but it says something in
there like you could talk you so blue in
the face and these some of these people
are never going to believe you they're
never going to hear you I put something
over their heart or over their mind or
over their eyes and they're not going to
see it they're not going to see it so
don't waste your time so I used to
but then in other places in the Quran it
says strive and argue and with the best
manners and go at these people and
sometimes even be harsh and and so
there's like a you've got to understand
the meanings and the contest and stuff
and I'm learning more about it but what
I'm seeing is when I get into a dialogue
with somebody if I sense that they're a
closed mind it's kind of like you know
the guidance prayer the guys how do you
know if what God's saying what Allah is
saying when you pray the guidance peer
my own said if your heart if it feels
like your rib cage is opening and if you
loose and good it say yes and if you
feel all tight it's a no what's the same
anything would I believe would give and
our with people I'm going with the same
feelings if I'm talking to somebody and
they're Rhys and they're listening to me
they don't have to agree with everything
I'm saying but if I'm talking to a an
open mind an objective open mind that's
willing to connect and communicate on a
on us on a level playing field and
respect and talking about the
information and no attacking the people
then you go and if somebody starts
attacking you you know you're in the
wrong ball for your right you know
you're in the wrong place you dust your
you know Jesus gave directions to his to
his companions when he sent him out he
said you go yeah you'd knock on the door
you say Salam alaikum you make the Dawa
you give it you invite him to monotheism
and if they don't like you you dust off
your feet and you keep going mmm you
don't stand there and argue with him or
try to convince him or try to close them
and even Muhammad used to stress on this
peace be upon him used to anguish over
this and Muhammad and Allah said your
your what do you gonna kill yourself
over this he says you're there Warner
you're not there Guardian and the same
goes for us and I know how it feels you
have a big heart look at what you're
doing with your life
you're putting it out there for
everybody and you're trying to go all
you're doing you just like trying to
just share with people the best you have
and it's like don't waste your time
jesus also said peace be upon him don't
cast pearls before swine and I don't
mean people are swine but sometimes the
mind is swine light meaning that it
could take something valuable and
[ __ ] yeah there's our so when someone no
get ahead finish go ahead when someone
go ahead that's so I was gonna say I'm
learning to discern more who I should
spend time with sharing information and
who to just say peace to and walk away
yes yeah that was that ayah that was on
surah bakra the is-6 anele anele Edenic
FR no será una ley him under to whom and
under whom la home la you mean oh yeah
as to those who reject faith it is the
same whether you warn them warn them not
they will not believe in Allah the
Creator had set a seal on their hearts
and on their hearing and on their eyes
as of a little penalty they incurred so
this is the the verse that you were
referring to yeah and it's like I'm not
cursing them and I'm not judging them
I'm just saying hey if you're not gonna
door and the door opens it says somebody
says come in you go in but if you knock
on the door and the door doesn't open
and people are cursing at you through
the door you should turn around and walk
away it's real simple
esse so now with this whole global
pandemic that's going on you said you
have it's business as usual for you
you're staying home you're doing what
you'd normally do but you mentioned some
some some some some things that behind
the scene that that were potentially
happening that many of the the people
are unaware of like what are some of
these things that you feel from your
research are things that are kind of do
you feel going on behind the scenes well
okay yeah I get you I'm not I don't know
the future I'm not a fortune-teller and
may Allah forbid me from ever pretending
to be or even assuming to be or anything
like that
but it says in the Quran somewhere Allah
does give some people insight and
there's a way to be something like a
messenger and a prophet but not be a
messenger and a prophet and again I
don't know that chapter and verse but I
know it's there I don't know the
but so I don't feel special better
holier than thou any of that but I just
feel like Allah gave me a gift okay and
the gift you know I nose fisheye lenses
that sometimes objects appear closer
together than they are I feel like you
put one in my brain okay
so I'm just gonna say a few things but
inshallah I don't know if this is going
to happen or not these are just things I
see on the horizon is this from the
business from you going down these
investigating researching yes yes I'm
sorry I mean to catch up a little bit of
a delay here yeah okay number one I
believe that the karana virus is another
false flag even more horrific than 9/11
it's already killed way more people than
happened on 9/11
Bill Gates owns a factory in Wuhan China
that manufactures biochemistry
biochemical testing and stuff he also
has the patent on the corona virus and
also on the on the cure on the Panda on
the vaccination for it and he also is
into eugenics big time he wants to
depopulate the planet to find you know
to like 500 million people it's like the
Georgia Guidestones thing where to make
it sustainable but this has been going
on what's happening what I'm seeing
happening he is in 3d real-time things
are happening that I was thinking about
and reading about and dreaming about
with over the last 57 years the
one-world government coming closer the
cashless society coming closer if nobody
is going to use cash anymore
that what they want to do is they want
to Bill Gates wants to chip everybody
before he wants to tag us before he lets
us out did you hear about this one they
want to tag us they want to put a
microchip into us that will have
everything on us everything our bank
account or social security or insurance
our health records everything so if we
act up they can turn us off there was a
movie called the net with Sandra Bullock
in the 90s it was like that it was like
a premonition of this they want to chip
us this state a lot of people believe
this is the mark of the beast we
is this chip that they want to put into
into our bodies in our in our hand area
or in our forehead area where the
compare they could just scan us okay and
you don't have to carry money anymore
keys ID nothing it's all in there oh how
great this is gonna be I feel like it's
uh and I would rather have my head cut
off
now now is this now is now is this where
people is are these like where you would
say okay now this is our conspiracy
theories is this something that now
people can go research rare fine yeah
research it it's everywhere they're
already chipping dogs pets teenagers
wayward teenagers people in old folks
homes people with Alzheimer's diseases
I believe the Prince of was Prince
Charles and the royal family got shipped
some corporations are doing it other how
much easier it's gonna make it oh it's
becoming popular there's a company
called verichip I was looking at this 20
years ago there was a company called
mondex which was promoting the cashless
society
I did see I did see on on al Jazeera
they they had and I think was a Sweden
or Denmark they were showing people
getting chipped and having chipping
places I saw that so I did see that
today I refer there in a hurry to roll
this out and these lithium batteries are
gonna malfunction and a lot of people
are gonna anyway but this is the mark I
believe this could on this thing as a
UPC code okay we're gonna be basically
like commodities we're gonna be like and
we're gonna because they're gonna know
where we are what we're doing they'll be
able to listen in there we have they'll
be able to mic us they'll be able to
watch I mean they just want to lock down
the human race and just play golf or
something I don't know what they want to
do but they want to lock down maybe they
want to have their their blood parties
or whatever they do but may Allah forbid
it they're gonna get away with it for a
little while and you say hey what do you
mean they when you say they who's they
okay there's a combination of people all
right
you've got it's the one world government
it's the new world order people it's the
ultra filthy obscenely rich ones that
now there are probably some really
really obscenely rich people that are
probably good people but they're few and
far between because in order to get that
rich you got a sell would buy a lot of
your soul up you got to give up a lot
for a limb for most of the people
there's probably a few that did it's a
good way but you're asking me what's the
quiz repeat when you say day we heard
this Detroit lad all right if you want
to put a name on some of these groups
the Trilateral Commission the the
Council of Foreign Relations CFR
trilateral commission CFR Bilderberg
Group these groups were people these
ultra rich people get together and party
Bohemian Grove do all sorts of weird
stuff but they're basically planning out
their sitting down with a clipboard
planning out the world is this something
are they are this is it does this have
anything to do with the person that had
that island and they were bringing
children on and this is Jeffrey upstate
yeah that's something that was obviously
that was something I was if you were to
talk about it people think you're making
something up conspiracy theorists but
this was actually uncovered that they
had an island and they were having their
pedophiles on that island and they were
raping and doing whatever with sex
slaves with children they're finding
bones on the beach and the water they're
finding skeletons underground and stuff
I believe I don't have proof you know
intuition is a wonderful thing you know
I I go on intuition a lot because people
can make up information and in this day
and age you could make a video video can
be faked anything can be faked I go on
my intuition and Allah gave me a lot
because it's guided me to him and my
intuition it tells me plus some news
reports I read is that this man Jeffrey
Epstein worked for Mossad which is
Israeli Secret Service and he had files
on all the world leaders doing atrocious
things to children and he was basically
blackmailing the leaders of
the world and I believe that was his
mission along with this lady who worked
with him who mysteriously got away yeah
I believe that he worked for Mossad
Israeli Secret Service and that he his
job or part of his mission was to you
know put put world leaders into
compromising situations so he could
control them so his so the Zion is could
control the world the rest of these
people okay i i'm not i'm not saying
myself that i that i believe in and any
of these things i just don't i don't
know and i think that i don't either
i believe it i don't know yeah and but i
know that we have been lied to
there are things going on that there
that's another pay level another level
of clearance
one might say i was a CI director we
lied we cheated me steal stole it's like
we had the entire entire training
courses but there are things that are
going on behind the scenes we've been so
many lies have unfolded i was the CI a--
director we lied we cheated we steal all
so many things that we've been told the
general public and it's been lie after
lie after lie so if a liar comes to you
with some news the creator of the
heavens and earth Allah samantha law
tells us if a faucet comes to us go
verify check it up you know so that's as
yes as we should i mean we should be
people who go verify we should go check
in a lot of times you're not going to
get the truth from the mainstream media
you have to go out elsewhere see
absolutely absolutely there's a lot of
credible people online a lot of very
credible people online x veterans x
people who were in the government
because they know they're not going to
get justice in the media so they're
they're putting it out online yeah and
they're talking about it yes mm-hmm
there's a woman named Katherine austin
Fitz she was in the Bush administration
at 9/11 she left
she's got an organization called Solari
Sol AR I this woman is a mate she's
amazing and it would be great if you
could get her as a guest right go ahead
go ahead
and what
forget her Catherine Austen fits Solari
group
she's very astute about these things
from the inside looking out I mean she
was on the inside and she she became
aware of what was going on they try to
maintain what I try to do Eddie is
maintain the I try to keep my lens wide
because if you narrow your lens and you
start getting into the one event like
the buildings the Jets the virus this
that I want to maintain I want to keep
my focus that I'm on a journey that
Allah wins that this has all been
foretold that it's gonna be worse before
it gets better that Jesus peace be upon
him is coming back after the Antichrist
has been here for a little while and
that I just want to see his face smiling
at me again only only for real not in my
dream and not his face I want to see a
lot a smile a be in paradise and this
and I'm so to do that what I need to do
is focus on trying to do all the
obligatory things Allah wants me to do
which is pray and fast and and give
zakat when I can and go to Hajj when I
can and make Shahada and so on and so
forth you know and this is my folk you
know because I was a watcher
oh my since Kennedy I was a watcher
until I became Muslim and Allah has been
weaning me off with being a watcher of
the dunya and is starting to move me
more towards being a watcher of the Deen
yeah and and to be like just keep an eye
on the dunya but my focus is shifting
it's been 10 years now and I'm I feel
like I'm still watch the news I still
keep it on in the background sometimes
but I'm paying more attention to to what
I should to what I should be doing as a
Muslim and and what what we're my brain
where my consciousness and my body and
all everything needs to be as a Muslim
yeah you know traveling in this world
what I what I get from this is that it
actually increases my iman my faith
because when we say day I asked you
about they all also it says in the Quran
they plot and plan
and a lot of plans and not law is the
best of planners so if we believe in
Allah we believe in the enemy that he of
truth the satanic forces he believes yes
oh I think that I heard a nice statement
a brilliant statement where the person
was talking about that we most of us
have secularized the Shaitaan and what
happens is that we don't look that many
in these organizations what's like
Satan's hands in some of these organ
organizations so now when you have
someone who's obviously let's say a
doctor let's say a person that's running
who or running CDC and let's say for
just for argument's sake let's say or in
his example if the person has taqwa if
the person is living for Allah for the
hereafter yes if then you see that this
person is morally upright this person's
sound but when you have when you have
someone who's far away from Allah when
people worship money and who are
involved in these in these secret
movements and and also sell their souls
you just don't know what to expect and
you don't know what can be happening
behind the scene but this for myself it
increases my mind knowing that you know
when some lot of these things uncovered
that you know there are sick people out
there there people have submitted
themselves to the Shaitaan who worship
money power Fame and and and and and
they're their lost souls they need Islam
more than ever because this is the ones
that are lost one thought talks about
who are spreading you know they say
they're spreading peace but they're the
ones who are actually spreading mischief
all over the world yes yes so I find
peace in knowing believing with
certainty that I'm on the right track
and I'm on the straight path
I encourage good and I forbid evil
whenever I can I try to avoid as I say
verbal Cagefighting yeah
try to keep my body healthy try to take
care of my wife and and my and my family
help as I can and whatever limited help
I can give and watch watch the watch
should go by watch the world go by
because because this is all it's gonna
dis
everybody screaming about Trump Trump
saw Trump so sideshow Trump's a opening
act it's going to get a lot worse before
it gets better and I know this is true
because a lot of said so and you know I
just want to it's like you know the
Sprint versus the cross-country you got
to pace yourself
we're in a long run here we're in a long
run we got to pace ourselves
and we don't want to burn out you know
sprint go sprint and on on a you know
get lost in one of these one of these
one of these one of these what do they
call him now on TV when they drop
something for you to go it's like when
you'd play with a ball of yarn and a
kitty kid they I forget what they call
it talking points or something they just
throw something out into the into the
media so people will be distracted while
they're doing this other thing over here
on this other thing the three-card Monte
you know what don't watch my hands you
know yeah so does it's a focus that the
fact that we're living in our world
that's about to go through some the most
major change it's ever gone through and
that and that allies gonna is going to
make everything right and and that death
is not the end of the road nor is it a
punishment this is a very important
thing to instill in all in all of us is
to remember that death is not the end of
the road nor is it a punishment
everybody tastes death so this is not
what we we shouldn't be afraid of dying
and if you and if you put and if you and
you know we all know that you know a lot
of people think you know being a martyr
is a Muslim martyr is like some guy who
blows people up and we know that our
terrorist who goes to the Hellfire we
know that Allah hates terrorism and
forbids terrorism it's a big lie it's a
big sin
yeah that way I just want to stay on
this from you and do what I can to help
on the way everybody along the way who I
meet to try to help people will point
him in the right direct what I believe
to be the right and it was so grateful
you know this is the Eddie we're alive
at the most incredible time in human
history it just blows me away and I
sometimes I feel like a lie I can't take
this is gonna be too and then a lot but
says no I don't think this you can't
handle so anybody that's on earth right
now it's gonna be going through a lot
and I just ask Allah to make it easy as
easy as possible for a review on it's
bad ones who who love him and who babe I
wasn't you were cutting out there can
you hear me yeah did you hear that last
part say it again
it was breaking out I just asked a lot
of to guide everyone especially
or guide them you know when I first
became Muslim
you know I was told you know you you can
pray for non-muslims one thing only
you can pray for them to be guided for
Muslims you can pray for okay
this is tough but any non-muslim deal
you make I was told by my Imam who said
you can pray for them to be guided yes
yes right so this is what I pray I pray
that the muskie guide had closed it too
along and the non-muslims be guided to
the threshold I mean and and and you
know Rome Roman Empire fell odd fell
Atlantis fell all these different
civilizations that were way ahead of us
technologically they forgot Allah and
they they're underwater or they're
underground
yeah and and you know the Hopi nation
who they're monotheistic although they
have spirits and all this but they do
believe that the America they said that
they have a prophecy of you they're
gonna watch the United States come and
they're gonna watch the United States go
and I'm not worried about that either I
got a good friend in Malaysia I'm gonna
go just kidding no I don't know it
doesn't matter where you are physically
it really doesn't matter where you are
physically yeah don't you try to save
your body you'll lose it try to save
your soul don't worry about your body
don't worry Allah will take care of that
last couple questions before we conclude
so okay people understand things in
context when you said you you believe
what you believe about the coronavirus
virus being a hoax what do you actually
mean I believe I don't believe it was an
accident that it was so you believe it's
synthetic that it was man-made
oh yeah oh yeah I don't believe its
naturally occurring at all no it's
weaponized some people had strokes from
this some people had heart attacks from
this some people lost their eyesight
from this some people their organs
turned into blow into water you haven't
have you
this virus is doing things to people you
would not believe somebody broke it down
and said some of the HIV is in this
virus there this virus is a Frankenstein
virus this is not just a naturally
occurring virus no I'm sorry I can't
show you the sheets
the government's sheet that proves this
look I've seen enough to know I have
seen enough to know there is paperwork
about it there are scholarly people
saying this but you know some a lot of
times they become more once I see it it
becomes more and more difficult to find
it on the Internet funny about that you
know you see something and then you go
WOW and then you look for it again you
go where it goes it's happening that's
happening - hmm so well whatever they
went spirit there's one big conspiracy
going on okay the conspiracy is this
Shaitaan is trying to make his last
stand and he's doing everything and he's
kicking out the jams and he's doing
everything in his power to to win and he
knows and he's not going to it so all
he's doing is trying to gather as many
souls as he can to take to the Hellfire
he knows he's not going to win he knows
that that's not his objective is to win
his objective is to take all these
people to hell and that's why I try to
talk to them with so much passion
because I know what's gonna happen to
them and it hurts me to let him go when
they're being obstinate or they're being
Cagefighting and stuff but you have to
the most compassionate thing the most
compassionate thing you can do sometimes
to let someone go when they when they
when they don't want to uh-huh you know
you know and go ahead and I wanted to
say something else I'm gonna name names
here I'm gonna name names you asked me
who are they I want to tell you right
now the Zionists are major players the
Zionists are major players and they've
been major players since before the
Bolshevik Revolution they killed twenty
million people in Russia they arranged
World War one they arranged no they
didn't they arranged from the United
States to get into World War one so they
could get Palestine from England in
return
see people wonder why did the Dwight add
Germans hate you so much why did
Sherman's hate you so much I don't know
how much time we got but I'll tell you a
quick one
Oh quick one Jews were getting kicked
out of places all over there all over
Europe they weren't doing good you know
and then Germany took him in I think it
was 17 or 1800s and they flourished the
Jews were welcomed with open arms in
Germany in that time 17 1800 now your
blood your father and mother are Jewish
yes they were okay and so what happened
was this World War one started England
was fighting England and Germany were
fighting who I don't know who was
fighting who but the thing was that
England was not good didn't look good
for England to win the Zionists the
German Jewish Zionists went to England
and said if we can get America into
World War 1 to help you win would you
give us Palestine and they said ok and
that's how the Balfour Declaration came
into being and that's how World War one
got into how the United States got in
World War one was the German Zionists
negotiated with the United States to get
into World War one and then what
happened was England turned around and
granted Palestine in the Balfour
Declaration - you know - the Zionists
and they and in the Balfour Declaration
they said everybody's gonna be play nice
and live together and be peaceful and it
was never entered into in good faith as
soon as they got their foot in the door
you know what happened look at it now
look at it now so they've been playing
this is um
no I'm not anti-semitic they're there
they're there they're major players but
they're not the only players yeah okay
but yeah you can't I mean how can you be
anti-semitic you're Jewish I mean your
your lineage is Jewish a similar the
words that might mean someone from
Southwest Asia most of those Jews over
there are not Semites yeah they're from
Eastern Europe there are no zis a Semite
is a person the Palestinians are the
Semites yeah a Semite is a person from
southeast Southwest Asia which is Asia
Minor yeah um these people running
around like Netanyahu's from Poland he's
not he's not a Semite he's you know
accused of people of anti-semitism I
don't want people said do you understand
yeah I understand but just to clarify
you know mother
Jews were actually fleeing persecution
coming into Muslim lands and there was
always a a pretty good relationship
saving the Jews from there's a dr.
Weinstein I believe professor who said
that Islam saved the jury I mean the
Jewish people it's in the Jewish chronic
yes yeah yes saving of Jews during World
War two there's a lot there's this a lot
of propaganda that Muslims hate Jews and
all of this well there is a picture of
some Imam with Hitler meeting and
talking and they used that to say oh the
Muslims were involved and I don't know
about that but I I know more stories
about good decent Muslim people who
saved Jewish people during the war and
this is it's our commandment we're
supposed to work with the oppressed help
the oppressed whoever they are not just
Muslim oppressed
it's a commandment from Allah you know
somebody's getting depressed and we
don't help them this is just could put
us into the Hellfire yeah we don't want
to do that yeah so I guess from all of
this the reality is that we have a
purpose
this life is not purposeless that there
is a creator he sent guidance you found
it and you were a true seeker you found
it in Islam the signs were clear and now
Islam gives us hope in all of this in a
world of darkness there's much good in
the world but there's also these like we
just talked about the Satanic forces
but sometimes for a lot of people get
overwhelming it could just seem dark and
gloomy but there's this life is short
it's a test and this helps us to stay
focused on the real life and that's in
the next life being good human beings in
this life worshiping one and only one
God and hopefully reuniting in Jena and
paradise and that's where the justice
truly will prevail on the day of
judgement and these people they those
people we talk about they they'll be
brought to account if they're not
brought to account in this life I ask
Allah to guide as many of them as
possible
yes away from the darkness I mean at the
rest of them the rest of them whatever
he wants to do with them because it's
his business is L AM Islam says love all
mankind and that's why we're sharing
this message peace acquired by
submission to the one and only one
creator that has an erv god almighty
allah thank you very much for sharing
your time with us and again your story
and some of these other things that we
talked about thank you Thank You Eddie
may Allah bless you and give you
everything in abundance that you need to
continue doing when you're doing and may
Allah guide you and I hope to see you in
this life and if not in this life maybe
we'll take a run in Jenna together log h
up thank you thank you so much
Salaam alaikum wa alaikum assalam - love
God